trois cent soixante six éditions cet été
encore la fête des loges revient d
attraction sur huit hectares au coeur de
la forêt de saint germain en laye un
événement ancré dans la commune depuis
le xiième siècle avant la fête il y
avait d'abord un pèlerinage il ya cet
enracinement historique qui est là elle
a une dimension aussi religieux c'était
une fête chrétienne notamment parce
qu'on célèbre tous les ans la saint
fiacre et le jour de la saint fiacre le
19 juillet cette année on a une une
messe qui est célébrée avec tous les
paroissiens de la ville sur les autos
tamponneuses avec l'évêque
c'est assez atypique mais ça fait partie
également de des traditions de cette
fête la fête des loges c'est maintenant
cette semaine de festivités et de jeu
auto tamponneuses train fantôme ou
encore tours ascensionnel mais c'est
aussi la solidarité
à chaque édition son association mise à
l'honneur cette année
il s'agit d' autour des williams elle
aide les malades du syndrome de williams
buren une maladie génétique orpheline
une grande partie des recettes de la
soirée d'ouverture a été reversée on a
récolté une somme gigantesque 27000
euros 27100 84 euros pour être très
précieux et 700 bêtes intégralement
affectés pour nos familles pour créer
des rencontres c'est là où vous pouvez
changer cela on peut parler si l'on peut
s'entraider
donc on va organiser une très grosse
fête pour parler et palotie aspects
médicaux si le beau temps se maintient
la fréquentation devrait être au rendez
vous la fête des loges c'est jusqu'au 19
août à saint germain en laye
[Musique]